Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my flash season 6 episode 10
video sort of an epilogue for crisis on
Infinite Earths and giving us our first
preview for how the multiverse has
changed and what earth prime is like now
that crisis has happened and they
rebooted everything with a brand new
timeline so if you're brand new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a new flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
Easter egg from the episode on the video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet we'll do top 10 and
Easter eggs as we go along starting with
number 10 the cold open it jitters so
they've used crisis to sort of refresh
some of the sets so they look a little
bit different jitters is just the first
one grand reopening they've been closed
for the last five months because of a
crisis they even call it out on a banner
I know we're all still freaking out
about the Ezra Miller Justice League
movie crossover with the flash because
the multiverse is back
they're also back to so technically all
the Justice League characters exist on
an unnamed earth they never really told
us which earth Ezra Miller came from but
remember all these normal people living
in Central City don't know the universe
was rebooted they don't know about DC
rebirth these people only know that the
anti-monitor attacked with all those
crazy shadow demon minions after they
rebooted everything so that's what
everybody's thinking about when they're
thinking about crisis but obviously we
the audience know about crisis on
Infinite Earths so it's also calling
that out in a meta way the barista calls
out via chinos remember that pretty much
every main character on team flash has a
coffee flavor drink named after them
because the big thing here number 9
is the brand new intro for the show I'm
assuming this is a permanent intro
that's going to play in front of all the
episodes now it got a huge glow up I'm a
big fan of the way they do this it's
designed as if you're taking the Flash's
perspective running through the Speed
Force passing by all these moments
quote-unquote in time with the current
main characters on the show number 8 big
Cisco's new pokedex of the flash
rogues so as he says some of them came
back to life after crisis when they
rebooted everything some of them got
changed in a big way the new version of
dr. light is just the first example that
one of the changed ones and the new
version of mirror master who obviously
I'll talk about because this episode
sort of sets them up as the next big
villain remember a crisis
bind all three different earths from the
main shows yeah black lightnings earth
and supergirls earth combined with earth
one so for the most part all the main
characters are on the same earth now the
vast majority these villains you'll
recognize from previous seasons on the
flash like some of them like the mist
for instance are from the very first
couple of episodes of the flash some of
them were killed off in earlier seasons
cisco's basically saying that everybody
in the binder came back to life so that
doesn't mean that we're going to see all
these new characters it just means that
we might see some of them in a new way
but I do like that they're keeping some
of the characters are the same like I do
hope that abracadabra comes back at some
point just because he's from so far in
the future you could have a lot of fun
with that there's a couple things that
are off in this binder you may have
noticed so Emily police see for instance
up in the right hand corner here isn't a
comic book character she's actually the
script coordinator in real life for the
flash TV show so some of these random
villains in the binder you don't get to
see every single face in the binder are
just members of the crew but the doctor
kimi o hoshi is obviously a hat tip for
the brand-new version of dr. light that
debuts later in the episode she is the
female doctor light in the comics but
way back during flash season 2 they
actually said that the flash TV show dr.
light was Linda Park from earth-2 and if
it wasn't clear yes there is still a
multiverse I'll talk about that in a
second because they played it in a
really weird way there were so many
questions in my timeline wait a minute
what happened to the multiverse how come
they don't think that there's a
multiverse Sisko calls out eden cores
they're a group from season 1 they were
eco-terrorists that they took down
rainbow Raider you'll remember was the
villain of the very first flash vs.
arrow crossover when he made the flash
go crazy and fight Oliver number 7 the
brand new map of Earth Prime
Cisco spent a bunch of time drawing up a
brand new timeline and a brand new
version of Earth primes cities where all
the heroes live now I don't think it's
the entire world it's just North America
a little bit of Africa because of
gorilla city but here you can see
National City is right next to star city
then Gotham is somewhere near Chicago
because Gotham in the DC universe is
sort of a stand-in for Chicago I know a
lot of people used to think that it was
way closer to the eastern seaboard but
the reason why Gotham looks like it's in
the Midwest is because like Christopher
Nolan for instance filmed his Gotham
City of The Dark Knight trilogy in real
world Chicago and they did that for the
Batwoman TV show too so
that's why it looks like it's in Chicago
over on the eastern seaboard zoom in
enhanced there are actually some bigger
Easter eggs you notice here that happy
Harbor metropolis and Freeland are all
right next to each other Freeland is
where the Black Lightning characters are
from but the biggest Easter Egg here is
happy Harbor so everybody that's a Young
Justice fan probably freaked out when
they saw this wait a minute they're
doing mount justice what's going on here
are we going to get a live-action Young
Justice TV show eventually I don't know
what their intention is to do with this
they might just move the quote-unquote
Superfriends base to the mount justice
here or they might just say that Wally
West when he's not on the TV show is
hanging out with his quote/unquote
friends at happy Harbor Wally West is
coming back in episode 14 in a couple
weeks that's also the episode where
reverse-flash is coming back it's going to
be like a really huge Speed Force
episode so I'll talk about that when we
get a trailer for it
Santa presa is featured during the
question comics Renee Montoya so I
always wonder if they're going to do the
question character at some point I think
there's some IP issues with that some
copyright issues but that's also where
they make Bane's venom to so obviously
that's all Batman comic book stuff
number six addressing the elephant
in the room the characters are acting
like they don't know that there's a
multiverse again but they rebooted
everything the multiverse is back all
the Smallville characters are back all
the earth two characters are back but
they spend the entire episode acting
like they're all still dead the way Marc
Guggenheim over on arrow explained this
is that is mostly done for the drama of
these secondary characters that don't
know only the main big characters know
about the multiverse coming back and
they just haven't told everyone else yet
for some weird reason there was this
huge dramatic arc between Cisco in
Nashville's character all this grief
that they're going through so I think
that it's just for the benefit of that
storyline they're keeping them in the
dark ignorant just so that they can do
that story which I don't think is a good
reason to do it
either way the multiverse is back so
earth to Harrison Wells Jesse quick
they're back everybody is back number
five Nash Wells is also back for the
rest of the season as they kind of imply
it wasn't really clear what they were
going to do with him at the beginning of
the episode because everybody still kind
of hates him because he was the pariah
character but now he's back to being
Nash wells he even named checks Atlantis
nice Aquaman Easter Egg I
know if there's an Atlantis on earth
Prime now I would assume that there is
but the map that Cisco drew wasn't at
the entire world so it was kind of hard
to see if he hadn't latest somewhere on
there they referenced the anti monitors
layer down in Nashville as tunnels
they're going to just double-check that
there aren't any problems there I think
that the showrunner talked about doing
some crazy sci-fi and cosmic stuff
though so we might actually see some new
gods Easter eggs happening in future
seasons number four welcome back
Diggle so obviously big crossover with
arrow is sort of an epilogue for
Oliver's death they had a funeral on the
final episode of arrow I did a whole
video for that they gave Diggle a Green
Lantern ring so I'll put a link for that
in the description but he reminds Barry
that he and Lyla are moving to
Metropolis with his brand-new shiny
Green Lantern ring ready for Superman
crossovers on that TV show he brings
back the mass that Barry gave Oliver at
the end of their very first appearance
in arrow season 2 episodes as part of
Oliver's last will and testament the
real reason why Oliver gave Barry the
mask back was just as a reminder for the
reason that Barry originally gave it to
Oliver to protect his family enjoy what
he has but they said Barry off on this
tear because he hasn't completely
processed his grief yet so he gets
obsessive over Clues and obviously
because he's a CSI he starts looking for
real clues that take them all the way to
Leanne you
diggle's being a real bro in this
episode so they have a couple of jokes
about him throwing up like he just
Wolf's down a whole bottle full of pills
before he speeds him off to Lian Yu
but you can tell Diggle is just rolling
his eyes into the back of his head when
Barry is talking about Clues like dude
it's just a mask there's nothing special
going on here but it is a cool
opportunity for a couple callbacks to
previous episodes of the show he also
drops a big near master Easter Egg when
he says he was running back on route 119
the flash vol 2 number 119 is a big Mir
Master verse the flash issue and there's
a giant mirror as we see it later in the
episode number 3 McColluch tech black
hole the new doctor light and Joseph
Carver so McCullouch Tech has been
around on the flash for the last couple
of seasons McCullouch tech obviously
named for Evan McCullouch the second
version of mirror master so we knew that
they were going to do him at some point
they introduced the mirror gun during
season 5 so it's just a question of when
we were going to see that new version of
master but the big twist is is that this
is another one of the flash rogues that
was changed because of the earth prime
changes just like we get a different
version of dr. light we get a different
version of mirror master evan mccullouch
in is ava mccullouch who is the CEO of
McCullouch tech Joseph Carver is also a
character from the very first flash
rebirth comic he debuts 'as this
scientist who's hit with the speed for
storm when it happens at the beginning
he doesn't get powers but it drives him
mad and he seeks to weaponize the Speed
Force eventually Berry is able to power
him down by siphoning speed from him the
same way we saw during crisis on
Infinite Earths remember how earth 90
Barry Allen John Wesley Shipp stole
Barry's speed for a brief period so that
he could destroy the anti monitors
machine he's like I gotta take this for
a second kid you run long enough you
learn a couple new tricks that's also a
bit of a hat tip that they're going to be
using that flash ability in future
episodes to like later in the episode on
Lian Yu Barry's Speed Force gets all
wonky there's going to be some weird speed
force storyline happening later this
season but as Barry and Diggle make it
to Lian Yu they go to the prison cell
where they kept Deathstroke nice
callback it was just a really small cell
so they didn't have to build a big step
for that but they reference
Ivo's freighter they referenced the
mirakuru so just because arrow is over
doesn't mean that they're going to stop
referencing big locations and big things
from the arrowverse remember the city is
right next to a lot of the other cities
where the other shows take place so
you'll see arrow characters showing up
on the other TV shows number two
cisco leaves the show for a little while
and team flash i'll explain what's going
on here because the showrunner in real
life came out and clarified how this is
all going to work cisco is back to having
no power so he just normal cisco but
because he's just freaking out he's
going to go on this walkabout and catalog
all the big changes he'll come back
later this season he hasn't left the
show effectively he's just going to be gone
for a little while we also get
confirmation on what's going on with
Nash wells
it's his daughter that he's looking for
his own version of Jesse quick except
his version looks like Allegra switch is
confirmation about why they've been so
weird about Allegra this season they've
been setting it up for the last several
episodes some of you have even commented
on it in my flash videos like does he
have a daughter that looks like Allegra
is that why he likes her so much so this
just confirms that but number one
obviously iris gets to me
the brand-new mirror master welcome to
the TV show so the post-credits scene
iris is walking by the mirror she starts
to piece things together wait a minute
my informant said something about a
mirror so she breaks into McCollough
Tech in Ava's office we also find out
she's connected to black hole because
that's how she unlocks the door then Ava
McCullouch winds up yanking her into the
mirror dimension through that giant
mirror they haven't completely explained
everything about her character but this
is obviously right out of the flash
comics the mirror dimension is just a
big thing that they haven't done yet the
new version of mirror master is just the
next big villain for the next arc but
not the rest of the season so I think
there's going to be one more big villain by
the end of the season but they haven't
said who that's going to be yet I know a
lot of you are holding out hope for a
version of red death on the TV show so
if we get any clues about that in
episodes all totally included my Easter
egg videos but if you spotted any big
Easter eggs that I didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the
comments and what will happen is is I'm
allowed to post my non-spoilery
birds of prey review later tonight so
look out for that as long as you have
alerts enabled for my channel you'll see
that video when I posted everyone click
here for my brand new Wandavision
trailer and click here for my brand new
Falcon and Winter Soldier trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!